day two ah it's um it's 251 I slept
terrible last night the house makes the
most ridiculous noises at night when the
heat goes on it goes every single heater
does that separately but at the same
time it's just an orchestra of creepy
noises that sounds like snakes I
wouldn't be scared of that normally but
I had a friend who had a snake
infestation when she was younger and it
was creepy there's also a lot of creaks
and clanks sounding like they're coming
from in the walls great great great
great great quickly quickly they sort of
work harmonious to create this one noise
that sounds like someone's walking
around in the house
I slept downstairs on the sofa I don't
necessarily know my rationale for doing
them to me it seems safer but if
someone's going to break into the house
they would break in on the first floor I
would be quickening my time of death or
quickening my time of serious harm and
injury the dog actually got into the
trash can last night on the paper that
they gave me that outlines everything
for taking care of the dog in big bold
blue letters the color did blue because
obviously was more important than
everything else that was written in
black it says do not feed cliff people
food I didn't feed it to him he got into
it but we went for a walk today I met
some of the neighbors they're really
nice his woman was coming towards us but
just had her hand crossed like this
I knew based on initial instinct that I
could take her but she knew the dog and
she was met us on the opposite side of
the block so that she could give
a treat the neighborhood likes this dog
pressure
cuz he's known they like him good coffee